The Shadow Lace Transfer Tool,
also known as Jaws,
is a handy device for transferring
stitches between the ribber
and the main bed.
It was originally designed
for Silver  / Singer / Studio machines
for a technique called shadow lace.
Most knitters use Jaws when transferring
a large number of stitches between
the beds, instead of just using a double
eyed needle and transferring
stitches one at a time.
Before working with the tool, let's
review how we transfer stitches manually.
Using the double eyed needle,
we position it opposite the ribber
and insert the hook of the needle
in the hole of the tool.
Pull up the needle and put
the stitch behind the latch.
Push down on the needle to slip
the stitch onto the tool.
Then slip the stitch
to the other end of the tool.
Position the eye of the tool over the hook
of the target needle
and slip the stitch off.
And we can do the same thing
by using two transfer tools.
Position the eyes of the first tool
over the needles to be transferred.
Pull up to get the stitches
behind the latches.
Push down to transfer
the stitches to the tool.
Insert the prongs of a second tool
in the stitches and transfer
the stitches to the second tool.
Set the first tool aside.
Slip the eyes of the tool over the hooks
of the target needles and slip
the stitches onto the needles.
Keeping these visuals in mind,
try transferring with Jaws.
Each side of the tool is numbered.
There's a number one and a number two.
Some jaws have two colors.
Start by making sure that the latches
of the needles on both beds are open.
Position the holes of side one over
the needles to be transferred.
Think of this as positioning
that double-eyed needle.
The way Jaws is constructed.
We can peek down between the sections
of the tool,
watch and confirm that the eyes are lining
up with the needles and that
stitches are transferring.
Pull up to move the stitches behind
the latches, push down
and rotate the tool so you can
transfer the stitches to the tool.
Here you can see the stitches are
no longer on the ribber needles.
But I missed one, so I'll just pick that
stitch up and transfer it to the tool.
Here's where that name Jaws comes in.
Close the tool and transfer
the stitches to side 2.
Shift the tool and position the eyes
of side two over the main bed needles.
Rotate the tool and pop those
stitches onto the new needles.
Keep in mind the process is like using
the double-eyed needle, but with Jaws,
you're transferring a number
of stitches at a time.